Speaker 1: Okay, let's now get into 2024.
Joe Biden's approval has absolutely collapsed.
Now, I was right there telling you when his
approval was low, but still historically higher
than many presidents at this point in time.
I was telling you that.
I was saying, yeah, it's low ish, but he's
still doing better than A, B, C, D presidents
at this point in their first term, you have
to go back to the 1940s now to find a first
term president with a lower approval rating
at this point, right July of the second year
of his presidency than Joe Biden.
And we're going to get to those numbers.
But this is coming at a time where also most
Democrats are saying they don't want Joe Biden
to run in 2024.
Now, I don't believe he is going to run in
2024, but we're going to get to that in a
moment.
Most Democrats don't want Biden in 24, a new
poll shows.
President Biden is facing an alarming level
of doubt from inside his own party.
64% of Democratic voters say they would prefer
a new standard bearer in 2024.
This is from a New York Times Siena College
poll.
Voters nationwide have soured on his leadership,
giving a meager 33% job approval rating.
We'll look at an average of approval rating
in a moment.
It's a little bit higher than that in this
particular poll.
It's at 33%.
Widespread concerns about the economy and
inflation have helped turn the national mood
decidedly dark, both on Biden and the trajectory
of the nation.
More than three quarters of registered voters
see the U.S. moving in the wrong direction.
A pervasive sense of pessimism that spans
every corner of the country, every age range,
every racial group, cities, suburbs and rural
areas, and both political parties.
Only 13% of American voters say the nation
is on the right track.
Now, in terms of approval.
Joe Biden's approval on average is down to
38.6%.
This is, as you can see here, the lowest of
his presidency.
He kicked off his presidency in the mid-fifties
and remained there for several months, then
started seeing a decline last summer as the
COVID surge happened.
Negative press about getting out of Afghanistan,
etc..
A brief bump towards the end of the year and
then a continued decline.
This is really not good.
And when you look at historical numbers, which
FiveThirtyEight allows you to do, you now
see that Joe Biden's approval rating has dipped
below where Donald Trump's was.
At this point in time.
We're roughly at day 550.
Where are we?
Roughly five.
But 545 of the presidency, Donald Trump had
a higher approval rating at this point.
Barack Obama had a higher approval rating
at this point.
George W Bush had a higher approval rating.
So did Clinton.
George H.W.
Bush was doing far better than then Biden
is now.
Reagan was doing better.
Jimmy Carter was doing better, although not
by much.
Gerald Ford was doing better.
Nixon was doing better.
LBJ was doing better.
JFK and Eisenhower.
You have to go all the way back to Harry Truman
in 1946 to find a president that around day
545 was had a lower approval than Joe Biden.
That's really, really bad.
I believe it is time for Joe Biden to soon
say I will not be running for reelection in
2024.
Make it public.
Make it clear.
Allow for anyone on the Democratic side to
have time to consider whether they want to
run for president in 2024, decide whether
they want to mount a campaign and to have
a clean, open primary for 2024.
And I say this for a few reasons.
Number one, I just don't think Joe Biden wants
to run for reelection.
That's the most important thing.
It's not about pushing Biden out.
It's I don't see any indication that he wants
to run.
He'll be 82 at the time.
The language continues to be that he intends
to run.
After Kamala Harris definitively said he was
running the next day, she had to walk it back
because it's very apparent to all of us that
it's not clear that he actually plans to run.
That's the primary reason he doesn't seem
to want to run.
And it's becoming.
Politically disadvantageous to Democrats,
for everybody to kind of have to pretend like
he is going to run.
I just don't think he's running.
Secondly, his approval rating is collapsing.
And whether it's Donald Trump or Ron DeSantis
or whoever on the Republican side, there is
going to be a major uphill battle for the
2024 election.
And it would seem prudent and better to not
rush anyone else into having to decide, Am
I getting in or am I getting out?
Make it clear I'm not going to be running
for reelection now.
I'm not actually saying that Biden should
announce this before the midterms.
It probably makes sense to wait for the midterms,
but it should be done relatively soon.
Again, Biden least popular president at this
point in his first term, dating back to Harry
Truman in the 1940s.
Third, even most Democrats don't want Joe
Biden to run.
So looking at the pulse of the party also
matters.
Now, I am right there with you in saying that
even most of those Democrats who would rather
someone other than Biden would almost certainly
vote for Biden if Biden is the nominee.
But it's not particularly reassuring when
it comes to the possibility that the right
will be really motivated in 2024.
Okay.
Sure.
Most Democrats, even if they would rather
someone else, would still vote for Biden.
But even if it depresses turnout by a couple
of points, I don't know that it's the the
advantage of the Democratic Party.
Now, there are many good options on the Democratic
side, but the question becomes this Kamala
Harris run and if so, do Biden and the DNC
attempt to sort of anoint her the de facto
nominee?
She's not popular either, and she may lose
a contested primary, but whatever is going
to happen, there should be time so that Democrats
don't get caught flat footed.
Now, let me say one other thing, because I
already know some of the messages that I'm
going to get.
There's a lot of kind of finger wagging going
on at people who aren't feeling inspired or
confident in Biden 2024.
The finger wagging should probably stop.
I'm not saying I wouldn't vote for Biden over
Trump or DeSantis in 2024.
I would.
I'm not even saying Joe Biden hasn't done
some good things.
He's done many good things, and I've enumerated
them many times.
I'm saying it would be better if Biden said
what most Democrats are thinking and said,
I'm not running for reelection.
We did a great thing here by taking the country
back from Trump.
We did A, B, C, D, and I am clearing the way
for a spirited primary where we are going
to get, I am sure, a great nominee to go up
against what is going to be a brutally desperate
attempt by Republicans to take back the White
House by any means necessary.
And we know what some of those means are.
That's what I think would be the best.
Now, if you disagree with me or you agree
with me, whatever I want to hear from you,
let me know what you think.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we will certainly follow up on this.
The David Pakman Show is a community, viewer
and listener supported program.
I would love for you to sign up at.
Join pacman dot com.
You can use the coupon code.
Big voting 22 to get a discount.
We do a bonus show every single day for our
members.
We also provide a commercial free audio and
video stream of the show roughly five or 6
hours earlier than we publish the show to
everybody.
And you also get a priority, a phone line
when we do our our viewer town halls, the
next of which is coming up soon.
I have to get the details on that.
That will be announced very soon.
Sign up
at join Pacman dot com.